après trois candidats et rennes voici
une nouvelle venue dans la collection
des embourbement la candidate nuxe de la
deuxième circuit du cantal quelques
mesures
au niveau de l'écologie et notamment par
rapport
aux trans tendres parce qu' on utilise
énormément la voiture donc ce serait
remettre des trains at il une limite et
de tout le monde après
[Rires]
elle est dans le pâté elle est dans le
pâté
une pièce qui nous emmène dans le monde
des lilliputiens personnages en guerre
car ils n'ont pas pu se mettre d'accord
sur la manière de manger un oeuf à la
coque faut-il le cas c'est par le petit
bout ou par le grand bout bref il vivre
ensemble mais c'est compliqué on se
croirait à la nuque est ce
le fut créée par les géniaux valérie le
sort et christian hecq
pour se déplacer ont été partenaires on
privilégie beaucoup le covoiturage ça
peut être ça ça peut être beaucoup de
juste comme ça parce que si j'ai pas de
ya pas de problème
à préparer elle était aussi préparent
aux débats que les autorités l'orga de
la finale de la ligue des champions on
attend de moi que je les fasse marrer
donc je vais essayer d'au moins remplir
cette case leur en soit paris qu'est ce
que vous redoutez le plus une juifs
non c'est là où il a pas été malin chris
rock il avait un plâtre pop la
montée je les vois arriver c'est à dire
que si c'est jacques weber qui vous
l'avez ça va être douloureux alors je
précise
que christian hecq ne joue pas le rôle
de l'oeuf à la coque
je préfère me la mettre moi-même comme
ça s'est fait dans les cérémonies quand
on fait des blagues sur la capillarité
d'un conjoint l'autre se lève et vient
giflé le présentateur
gagnons du temps attention questions sur
le financement la réponse vaut le détour
on peut très bien le faire aussi
l'argent on peut le trouver si on a
besoin le faux clé on peut pas laisser
les français comme ça
dans la pauvreté comme ça est ce qu'on
peut trouver cette heure où l on le
trouve je ne peux trouver cheveux et
économiste
gilbert
mais le reconnaître on est moderne et
modèle on sent des animosités pour
certains des bienveillance de l'autre
derrière moi je n'ai rien à craindre on
ne me donne jamais de molière humana
feeling de nakheel mais moi aussi jamais
nos me paraît que je travaille dans le
théâtre quelques années mais on ne nomme
jamais une irritation
nicomaque bernard une irritation parce
que parce que tu es complètement
excusez moi on peut peut partir saviez
vous qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour
s'envoyer en l'air moi j'espère une
grand-mère
aventure hier le record du monde de la
personne la plus âgée a réalisé un saut
en parachute en tandem son âge sans
trois ans après un atterrissage tout en
douceur des assistants se sont
précipités avec son déambulateur pour
l'aider à se relever ruth larsson a dit
sa joie aux caméras après son saut
qu'elle a raconté
c'était
des nouvelles rassurantes de francky
zapata je vais bien ça nous rappelle
qu'on n'est pas des oiseaux et que si on
n'est pas excellence et la gravité qui
gagne un trait d'humour mais l'inventeur
du trail board s'est fait une belle
frayeur samedi lors d'une démonstration
à biscarrosse l'homme volant comme on le
surnomme a perdu le contrôle de son
engin et s'est crashé dans un lac
pour le marseillais de 43 ans l'accident
pourrait être dû aux interférences
causées par les nombreux drones présents
ce jour là sur le site c'est bien connu
les français adorent la bande dessinée
il adore aussi chaussé patrick une bonne
il aime sauter cinq jours de vacances
[Rires]
et nouvelle
chaussée avec du pain mais encore plus
vraiment rien on dirait j'ai un truc je
crois je te regarde avec les yeux de
l'amour
carrément
c'est nous
avec symptômes
je tremble te faire un câlin
aussi rapidement ma foi
ça fait quatre mois 88e bon j'ai pas le
temps moi c'est moi j'ai une femme à
marier
non quoi je sais pas comment te dire
c'est que je ne veux pas été
rendez vous
[Musique]
ce soir j'ai envie qu'on apprenne à se
connaître c'est pas forcément envie car
rapprochement faut prendre son temps
pour moi donc j'ai envie déjà de savoir
qui il est avant de me donner
concrètement à lui donc
j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]